foreign
[Music]
thank you everyone for coming we're
really excited to be speaking here today
my name is Mike Stackhouse I'm the chief
Innovation officer of a Taurus research
and with me I have Jessica Higgins
director of analytics engineering but
really I'm a nerd who likes to code and
Jessica is a nerd who likes science and
coding today we're going to be talking
about our package our our package
t-plier and where I want to start with
this
is a little bit about why we made it
because typically I'm speaking at
industry conferences that are Pharma
Centric and specifically our pocket of
Pharma that we work in which is late
phase clinical trials so the first thing
to understand about programming for late
phase is that we're not doing as much
exploratory work which is what a lot of
the tools in the our ecosystem is built
for allowing you to explore your data
model and do all sorts of things but
when you're in late phase a lot of what
you need to do is already laid out for
you it's highly standardized you already
have basically all of the outputs that
you need to create so you're really
trying to operate more like a factory
so the first kind of principle of why we
made T pliers that summary tables are
highly repetitive so your code should be
highly reusable you want to operate like
a factory you're putting out maybe 300
tables for a single trial so you need to
get through that volume and you need to
get through it quickly so you really
want to be able to reuse that code
the second principle is that actually
for the outputs that we create
summarizing the data isn't what takes a
lot of time it's easy enough to pop a
variable into count or summarize and do
some means and standard deviations and
get those numbers that doesn't take much
time the Cosmetics of getting it to look
the way that your statistician acts asks
you to is what takes a lot of time so
the other thing that we tried to build
in the package is that text forwarding
of numbers or text formatting of numbers
can be very tedious so we wanted to make
it intuitive and easy
but this package has been out for two
years at this point and I've talked
about this enough that my team is
definitely sick about hearing it so the
new thing that um is the last principle
of what we've finally got in there with
is that we want to make t plier more
friendly for interactive tables so back
in 2020 we work with a lot of different
SAS programming groups who are looking
to adopt R and the question that I get
constantly is y r and it's the point
that was made to me early on that
resonated that I've never really
forgotten is that someone told me that
the cost of doing an additional say
adverse event table for a trial within
their company is free because you just
pop it into a SAS macro and out comes
the table and you're done and when
you're trying to talk about cost savings
and what R can do for you in that area
that's a hard thing to compete against
when the output is free so what does r
really have to offer and that gets into
the world of our markdown in shiny and
interactivity and that's where we really
want to make things more accessible
so just to give a little bit of
background on the package itself t-plier
it's an r package that we released back
in 2020 and I shamelessly
took the name from D plier and the
principle of from D plier that it's a
package
um a grammar of clinical summary tables
so
the reason that we try to make it a
grammar of summary tables is that we
wanted to take your focus off of doing
the actual summary and thinking about
the algorithms that you need to write to
do the summarization and how you get the
numbers
um that you want and really design it
more based off of describing the output
that you want to create so shifting that
focus of just saying this is what I want
to build a statistician typically what
you get your CSR and you get the mocks
of the tables that you need to produce
and that's going to have different
characteristics that are going to need
to be fulfilled so we wanted T player
syntax to focus on describing the output
and building up the characteristics and
then saying go and build this for me
the last thing was that we also wanted
to really draw our Line in the Sand I
did not want to Anchor into any specific
reporting package itself I favored
Huxtable early on because I had good RTF
support GT has been building up over the
last a few years and it's had an amazing
Place Jessica loves Flex table and then
in the shiny world you have things like
reactable so I wanted to make the things
that come out of our package really
easily accessible
to any styling package that you want to
create and we just wanted to really stop
at the character formatting and the
numbers so that that annoying part was
done for you and that you can pop it
into some other library that will
actually make it pretty I've never been
good at that that's why I hired Maya
um so to describe T plier itself I want
to thank Christina Fillmore for giving
me the best metaphor for this that I've
had which is think about cake
um so cake can take a lot of forms it
can have a lot of flavors and it can
have a lot of different decorations you
can have multiple layers into your cake
and those things can look differently
depending on how you build it up and
that's really what a t-plier table ends
up being so for a demographics table
which I have a concise example of up
here we have three different variables
from our data set that are being
summarized so we have the age group of
subjects which is a categorical variable
we have age which is a continuous
variable and then we have race which is
another categorical variable so for the
categorical variables you're going to
count you're going to represent percents
and then for the continuous variables
you're going to do different or
descriptive statistics for your N means
standard deviation so on and so forth
and then those things are all going to
be combined together and they're going
to have their different characteristics
of how you want that styled and we're
going to bake our cake and pop that out
and you get the data frame all collected
together and assembled and ready
formatted so that you can go and put
that into some sort of presentation
but our Focus here today and what we're
talking about for t-plier today is what
metadata can really bring to the table
so the question that we're trying to
answer and what we're trying to make
accessible here is that when you look at
a result on the table
asking the question what data produced
that result so if I look at this table I
know that I have six subjects in the low
dose subgroup who are black or
African-American but who are the six
subjects what are the data that summer
or were summarized to actually produce
that result
if I'm looking at the median of the
high-dose group again what data produced
that result what subjects were fed in
what was the data that went into my D
pliers summarized and went through the
median function to actually produce that
result because these are questions that
are often asked when you want to drill
down into your data and understand more
about it so specifically when we talk
about metadata within t-plier we're
asking two different questions what
variables were necessary to derive that
result and what filters were necessary
to derive that result so really what is
the slice of data picking out the
different columns and the different rows
that were actually necessary to produce
the result that you see on the table
and here I will hand it over to Jess
okay
[Music]
for giving us a whole a great intro on
why uh you created T player and now
we've talked about what do we mean by
metadata
so how are we going to harness this
metadata
so in this process you've created your T
player table which produces your summary
data frame these are the results you see
you would see them on paper if you
printed it out
um and additionally what we're doing
here now is that including this table
metadata that that metadata remember
those are the names and the variables
used to to create that result and we can
use that metadata to create the relevant
subset and we can wrap all of this in a
really easy shiny application to create
an interactive table that upon a click
action will give us both our summary
table and the res and the actual data
that produced that result
so
what does this look like and building it
so how do you get that metadata how do
you do you have to save very simple
so creating the metadata all you have to
do is change the argument metadata
equals true and the the what will happen
is your the metadata for this for your
table will just be created automatically
for example we have our result output
data frame and now you can see what's
actually added to the table is the T
player metadata object so each cell
contains a t the with this object and
this object is the metadata again those
variables those names that created that
specific result cell
as we were talking about earlier this is
indicated by a row ID and a column ID
and we can find go from there to find
who are who are these people they're not
just numbers in the summary table these
are subjects in a clinical trial
so we've got this metadata how do we
extract it what do we see
um and we get to this as I mentioned the
input is really simple you supply it a t
player table a row ID and a column name
and the output what I really like about
this is that you can see okay these are
the names that are required to create
this result I already know what columns
I'm looking at these are the filters and
you can see exactly what
um what it looks like what are those the
filters that are going in to that result
saying great I see this where the heck
is that subset what is this data
this is a really simple function too
again give it it's a new function get
meta subset you provide the same inputs
and it produces that subset that subset
of data that produced your results you
can see exactly who is in that result
additionally
this get meta subset function includes a
an additional argument to add relevant
columns that might give your subset a
little additional context it defaults to
U sub ID
which is um for those of you in the the
world it's a a c disk specific
um
variable that all these data sets have
however you can change it to whatever
you want this is the only place where
any clinical or C disk specific defaults
or language is used in this package we
really want T player to be extensible
Beyond just using finished C disk data
but this is the one place where where
you see it
so to summarize we've created our T
player table which includes our summary
results
um we've got our relevant metadata our
filters and names we can create the
subset to see that what does this
actually look like in an interactive
table
so
let me give you a quick little demo what
you're going to see is
the most Bare Bones basic shiny app ever
created
I'm actually I'm pretty proud of this
fact I didn't create it but I could and
I'm not a shiny developer
um
it's coming here it is all its Glory
um in fact it's so simple it's 85 lines
long which I had to look up and was
again you can see the code we will
provide that
so what do we have here you can drive
around
um
so you want to see as we mentioned
earlier we were looking at who are those
um eight subjects in the placebo group
that are black or African-American you
click on the result
and your metadata subset pops up you can
see it you can check
so this is incredibly useful
um I've as someone who spent a lot of
time looking at summary tables then
looking at a really long listing trying
to find those people individually uh or
programming it on the side while you're
comparing at a summary table
to be able to see the all of these
things at once to take your review from
a sort of very manual process to
something that's interactive that's
quick that's fast
it's just all about it's what we're
about trying to make things quicker
faster and easier and to bring farm
along in that process
slowly
so
okay that's great regular summary table
these are pretty common what about if
you want to
um we want to if you are in an example
of where you have let's say you have a
summary table and you've included some
additional statistical analyzes or
models and you have those results uh
that you want to share and you also want
to include the metadata for that test
you want to know exactly what subjects
went into the analysis you a t player is
very you can extend and append the
metadata you can create a new metadata
object you can add those filters and
names that will help created
um
the results and in addition and my
favorite part is you don't actually need
a t-plier table to do this this will
work with a data frame I was just
recently thinking about the context of
this in my waveformer life I was an
evolutionary biologist I worked with a
lot of butterflies and I used to put
them in models and I was like man if I
could have seen the subset that would go
into that at that time would be really
useful so I can see how I would I
personally would have taken this and and
used it in my own work so
um again extending that metadata adding
that metadata to your directly to your
results so you can pull it up as needed
we'll show it quick this joining up
again really simple so now we're looking
at we have the results of a dose
response model
um
between
high and low I think I can't see that
well
um but again you're going to see like
who's in who's in this model what are
the subjects here what is the data
that's included in this model you can
click on this really simple interactive
table and
um the results are produced and right
there for you it's a really quick and
snazzy way to see your results and the
metadata that created them all at once
um and with that like I said
um we're really excited at how we're
sort of
getting some of these the idea of taking
these formerly paper clinical tables and
moving them into more of a screen
friendly format into a quick review
format and a way that you can keep
moving forward thank you
[Applause]
[Music]